amazing
[Music]
Savannah Chrisley shares what it's like
raising her sister Chloe while parents
Todd and Julie are in prison we need to
figure out healthier ways to cope with
things and deal with things and even if
it's just little things that I'm trying
to implement because I'm not their mom
I'm not their dad I'm I'm their sister
look any family who faces a loved one
going to prison
um it's a very difficult challenge but
they're strong they're faithful check
out the sisters celebrating Chloe's
school day being canceled
[Music]
oh
the ten-year-old also had a little
celebratory moment for herself schools
canceled tomorrow
[Music]
and Chloe she is she
is amazing she's the boss she he truly
is she is the boss Chloe is actually
taught in Julie's granddaughter the
child of Todd's son Kyle from a previous
marriage they obtained custody amid
Kyle's struggles with addiction I have
officially raised children my entire
life
and just I was that close to a clean
getaway and then all of a sudden here
comes my club bug knocking on the door
we're starting over and now Todd and
Julie are sort of Starting Over Again
adjusting to their new normal Behind
Bars serving a combined 19-year prison
sentence after being convicted of fraud
I had a conversation with my dad and he
was like you know what Savannah this is
going to be the hardest but most
rewarding thing you've ever done
but taking care of Chloe and her 16 year
old brother Grayson hasn't been easy the
other night I just had a full on
breakdown and was trying to find Chloe
proper clothes to go and visit my
parents and find her hair stuff and I
just sat down on the floor and just
started crying with Chloe and Grayson
I'm like you know what they need to see
peace and calmness you know Chloe's 10
years old and I know that she's on TV at
certain times but outside of that I
think it's probably that Chloe best that
Chloe be allowed to grow up is any other
10 year old would
and Chloe she thinks her big sis is
doing just fine watching over her the
next day Chloe and I were talking we
were in the car and she was like you're
doing a pretty good job
[Music]